[Music]
do you ever wish time would slow down a
little bit maybe to spend more time on
Hobbies or with family or just to enjoy
your morning coffee well you're in luck
because all you need to do is travel
close to the speed of light and time
dilation will take care of the rest
sort of
I'm rich Burnett for one dream and in
this episode of perspectives three
experts discuss the philosophy and
science of space and time and how they
unify into what we call space time
We Begin now with a few of Newton and
Einstein's thoughts on how we measure
time
for Newton time is absolute God wears
the Divine Rolex and all of reality is
divided up into absolute time slices
that is three-dimensional spaces
arranged in an absolute order think of a
film not the movie you watch but the
film itself on the Reel that would go
through the projector
it was a long strip comprised of
individual frames each frame is the
entirety of space and the Order of the
frames is the entirety of time for the
movie
film space is absolute because for each
thing we can say exactly how far
something is over and up from the bottom
left hand corner of the frame in which
it appears and time is absolute because
we can say exactly how many frames into
the movie it is
space and time are both absolute and
independent
Einstein knew this concept of space was
wrong his hero H.A Lawrence had
described the way lengths contract for
moving Observers
but no one understood why this happened
indeed pretty much everyone including
Lawrence himself thought it was a quirk
of math it didn't really happen
but Einstein took the math seriously the
transformation equation said it did so
that's what the physics tells us about
the world
but why
it took a long walk in the mountains
with a friend thinking about this
question he took the train back home to
Barron glancing over his shoulder at the
clock on the train station as he walked
away from it it hit him
the clock does not show what time it is
the clock shows what time it was to read
the clock light bounces off the clock
and travels to your eye
but he was walking away from the clock
the light would not only have to reach
him it would have to catch up with him
to do it if an observer moves away from
the clock the light would arrive
slightly later the faster he went the
more it would have to do to catch up to
him so the faster he walked away from
the clock the slower the clock would
appear to move
remember that Einstein at this point was
under the spell of ashdomach's
positivism what is real is what's
observable what we measure Heim is what
the clock tells us it is so if the clock
is moving slower for removing observers
then time itself slows when observers
move
what Lawrence had done for length also
needed to be done for duration this was
the key to the special theory of
relativity
this effect is called time dilation time
passes at different rates for different
observers moving at different speeds
it was most colorfully illustrated by
Einstein's friend the French physicist
Paul langivan with his famous twins
paradox
suppose we have two twins who are both
20 years old one stays on Earth while
the other becomes an astronaut
the astronaut travels very fast for the
duration of the mission returning to
Earth 20 Earth years later the twin who
was left on Earth will be 20 years older
that is 40 years old the twin stepping
out of the rocket will only be 37 years
old the astronaut twin doesn't just look
younger but using a clock in a calendar
would have only experienced 17 years in
the same time the Earthbound twin
experienced 20. the passing of time is a
relative measure
Einstein understood this
but he did not however fully understand
the philosophically radical nature of
the Insight after he published it the
paper was read by a mathematician turned
physicist named Hermann minkowsky who
did understand exactly how radical it
was minkowski had been one of Einstein's
teachers and was a better mathematician
than Einstein what he realized was that
Einstein had unified space and time into
what we now call space time
essentially space and time are now known
to be the same thing
further what he realized was that
Einstein's transformation equations were
just rotations in space-time
but what it means to do a rotation in
space time is tough to get your head
around so let's use a familiar analogy
of a two-dimensional Vector from
introductory algebra
start out drawing an X and Y axis in a
vector of some fixed length now let's
spin that Vector however we want it can
point along the x-axis with nothing
along the y-axis or it could go the
other way pointing along the y-axis and
not the x or it could Point somewhere
between the two pointing a little bit in
the X Direction and a little bit in the
y direction
no matter what direction the vector
points the length is always the same so
that's one conclusion the length of the
vector doesn't care about X and Y
individually and equivalently you could
keep the vector stationary and rotate
the axes the projections of the vector
on the X and Y axes change even though
the vector doesn't that is at the core
of minkowski's insight
in relativity the mathematics are pretty
similar now instead of X and Y being the
horizontal and vertical axes just
imagine that the horizontal axis of
space and the vertical axis is time
so let's think about a person who is
stationary in space
they only experience translations
through time and none through space so
their space time Vector is pointing
upwards along the time axis
on the other hand we saw that a person
moving faster and faster compared to you
experienced times that were shorter and
shorter and when you get to the speed of
light the time experienced by that
person eventually goes to zero so at the
speed of light there is only moving
through space and no movement Through
Time
that means that the space-time Vector
becomes horizontal
the only changes to experience are in
space while there's no changes in time
and of course if a person is moving at a
velocity through space less than the
speed of light they're experiencing both
changes in space and time
the important point is that a person's
space-time Vector that is the combined
experience of both space and time is
unchanged one person might experience
more space and less time while another
might experience more time and less
space but the combination the length of
the space-time Vector is something
everyone agrees on
and this has absolutely huge
consequences it means that a person's
velocity through space-time is constant
and further their speed is the speed of
light
a stationary person is moving through
time at the speed of light while a
person moving a hundred percent through
space and not at all through time is
moving at the speed of light through
space
and that is a deep and fundamental and
completely satisfying answer for the
question of why can't you go faster than
the speed of light it's because
everything is always going at that one
single speed and it also shows in the
most intimate of ways how space and time
are one in the same and how you
experience the two is just a matter of
perspective
no relativity had explained the
relationship between space and time
general relativity which Einstein
developed between 1907 and 1915 expanded
this work to describe the relationship
between space time and gravity
we imagine this today by invoking the
concept of space-time with space and
time inextricably linked to make up the
fabric of our universe
in special relativity we imagine
space-time as flat with something like
light traveling neatly along straight
lines
but in general relativity when we
introduce gravity space-time becomes
curved
an object with a lot of mass like a
planet or star will affect space-time
thanks to the effects of its
gravitational field warping the fabric
of the universe and appearing to bend
the path that light takes as it travels
changing its apparent position and
travel time
according to general relativity our own
sun should influence the light of
background stars as it passes in front
of them
the subtle warping of space-time from
our Sun's mass should deflect the path
of the light as it travels from the
background stars to Earth
suddenly Shifting the apparent position
of stars near the Sun
Einstein's general relativity equations
allowed him to calculate exactly what
this expected shift would be
and while it was small the observational
astronomy Experts of the era like George
Ellery Hale confirmed to Einstein that
it would be detectable with cutting-edge
telescope technology
the difficulty of course is that when
the sun is visible it outshines the
light of any stars in the sky
for the best test astronomers would need
to observe Stars Incredibly Close to the
sun right at the most blinding point in
the daytime sky
the only way to accomplish this would be
during a total solar eclipse
at the moment of totality a few short
minutes when the moon perfectly blocks
the Sun
the sun would be in position to bend the
light of background stars and the Stars
themselves would actually be visible
astronomical photographs of those Stars
near the sun taken during an eclipse
could then show whether there was the
shift in a parent position predicted by
Einstein so the British astronomer
Arthur Stanley Eddington was placed in
charge of a project that sent two
Expeditions out to observe the eclipse
of 1990. one in South America and one
off the coast of Africa
we knew that's what the sky would look
like if the sun were not so bright and
it's what the night sky looked like six
months earlier when we were on the other
side of the Sun so when the eclipse
occurred we knew precisely what star
should be just next to the blocked out
Sun
if Newton is right that star should
appear right where it's supposed to be
but if Einstein's right that star should
be shifted slightly it's light Bent by
the gravity of the Sun
eddington's team took photos the data
was analyzed and Einstein was spot on
word was sent immediately to Einstein in
Germany he opened the telegram read it
and calmly handed it to a graduate
student who was meeting with him at the
time
she read the news and knew what it meant
Einstein had changed everything the
evidence was in yet
the man was completely calm
shocked by his Placid demeanor she asked
what would Einstein have thought if the
results had been different if Newton's
predictions had been the ones that were
verified
he looked at her and said I would have
felt pity for the dear Lord the theory
is right
no one ever accused Albert Einstein of
excessive modesty
the idea that space's curve captured the
imagination it's responsible for much of
the long-distance travel in contemporary
science fiction hyperspace and Star Wars
Subspace and Star Trek if the special
theory of relativity is correct and the
greatest speed attainable is that of
light then most of the universe would be
inaccessible to beings with a limited
lifespan
so if we're going to explore the greater
Universe we need to travel faster than
the speed of light but that can't be
done
or can it the key to these sci-fi fixes
is to realize that when Einstein says
space-time itself is curved we're not
talking about a surface in space but
space itself
when trying to picture this we use the
example of a globe right that is a
two-dimensional surface on a sphere that
resides in a larger three-dimensional
world but for Einstein there is no
bigger Universe in which the universe is
set its space-time itself that Curves in
the presence of matter and other forms
of energy
this is hard to picture but the thought
on the part of Science Fiction writers
is that if I want to get from one place
on the earth's equator to another I
could follow the equator
following you know the shortest path on
the surface of the glove or I could
tunnel through the Earth and create a
straight line path that would be even
shorter by analogy if space-time curves
I could follow the path light takes the
shortest path in space or maybe I could
tunnel through space to create a
straight line and a shorter path
this would let me move faster than light
and allow in principle for travel to
otherwise inaccessible regions of the
universe through such wormholes or
hyperspace as we find in Star Trek Star
Wars and Doctor Who
each of these of course has its own way
of creating and massaging the root
through a non-existent trajectory in
space I'll leave it up to their
respective fan basis the hash out which
is most likely true given our best
theories of space-time emotion
gravitation
you'll find this a topic on which much
conversation exists much of it on the
internet
[Music]
thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
now on wandria